welcome back
to episode three of storycast 21
i'm jane secker millions of people run
marathons every year
attempting to complete the 26.2 miles of
42 kilometers
in as fast a time as possible but in
vienna in 2019
eliad kipchoge set out to become the
first person
ever to run the distance in under two
hours
an undertaking rated as difficult as
roger bannister's attempts to break the
four-minute mile
this is marathon man
i'm andy brady i'm a sky news
correspondent and in my spare time i'm
an amateur
marathon runner
in august of 2018 we went to kenya
my training partner and i for a new race
there's a series of marathons five
cross-country marathons in five days
and on the morning of the fifth marathon
when everyone's pretty broken up and
just wants to get it done and punch it
out
the organizer had said everyone that
gets to the finishing line
today right by all pejita
north of nairobi the capital
the incentive is eliot kipchoge is
coming down to present the medals it's
about 300 meters from the gates to the
finish line
elliot kipchoge my name is
okay i'm a marathon
i'm a sportsman by profession
i was born on 5th november 1984
in kenya he must have dreamed of these
moments
[Music]
and i i think they finished in pachetta
[Applause]
until i met him had always been this
kind of
rock star of running he'd won gold in
the marathon at the rio olympics
he had olympic medals going right back
to 2004
and was just a few weeks away from
setting a new world record
for the marathon with the time of two
hours one minute and 39 seconds
for me to meet him in kenya it was like
jumping through the screen in the cinema
i really am happy for his comment
actually
because i want to inspire people and i
want to be always next
to everybody who is who is human being
so i don't want to be so high
i want to be low particularly near the
people
i was intrigued by him his times
the victories the olympic medals
everything he's ever achieved
when i was a boy i really i was really
running fast and
i always imagined among the top in
running
so i think i enjoyed running from the
beginning
he was running his whole life he'd run
to school he'd run home from school
and then he would run off and sell dairy
milk
to keep the family finances going
full-time london marathon winner eliot
kipchoge
hoping to become the first person in
history to run a marathon
in under two hours
a couple of years before we met he had
tried to break two hours in monza
which is the formula one track in
northern italy i think i was like a
boxer
he was going to the ring and he doesn't
know whether he will be knocked out
or he will win by points
and i i missed by 25 seconds
he missed it by 25 seconds now in
marathon running
that's a lifetime scientists have been
looking at the running data of marathons
for decades and
it was their view that it could take 50
years before we'd see a human
if ever go under two hours i said to him
will you try again and he goes it will
be my dream to try again
i don't believe in limitations
i always say no human is limited let us
make everybody in the whole world to
believe that
if a human being could set a call
believe
and work on it you can achieve and i
think it was in his head at this stage
that if the opportunity presented itself
with the right team
he would absolutely try do it again
during 2019 uh my management actually
gives me a
hint that there is a big big company
called ineos
actually headquarters is in london they
wanted to see
a human being and making history
and we had a very good
meeting with the team ratcliffe on the
neos team
and i told them yes i'm ready to train
for it
and i go back to kenya to train for
london
marathon and then after london
immediately for the inus 159 challenge
in vienna
in october
blender is in vienna this morning where
that attempt is getting underway in the
next
few minutes uh ender the anticipation
building up
what are his chances in reality
the date was chosen as october the 12th
2019
and it was a university park and that
would be the route it would be lapse of
this park in vienna
and ineos had a vehicle which will be
driving and traveling at
precisely 13.1 miles per hour
with a laser beam being projected in
a horizontal line back
and that was the speed that green laser
was traveling
that was the speed kipchaga would have
to match
and run at to get under two hours
so there were 41 pacemakers in total
these were all guys capable of running a
kilometer
at 2 minutes 50 for 5 kilometers
the average fit person who runs
regularly
and he's fast will match kipchoger for
400 meters
and then they will burn off so the
pacemakers would peel in and peel off
one guy would join in at 10k another guy
drops out
and so forth it's a voted theme
to show the world that the best maker in
your life
it's the best way to follow a positive
mind in this world
i tell the best makers and everybody was
there let us
go up to the moon and come back to
hatake
this was the running equivalent of a
rocket
leaving earth they were the energy
he was in the cockpit and he needed them
to provide the energy get him to the
moon
and then land safely back on earth all
in one hour 59 minutes
well the stage is set now and it's over
to eliot kipchoga to run
his fastest this is where it will all
come to an end one way or the other and
if he crosses that line even a split
second under two hours
he knows he becomes a sporting immortal
for years when i got down to the
finishing line where
we started doing our reports it was very
difficult to gain access
we had all the correct press
accreditation unfortunately there was
like a vip
area that was sealed off
[Music]
how am i going to see this race how am i
going to commentate on us
and we're just literally by the side of
the street like everyone else
center is a shot yeah okay you go on tv
you know
there's something wrong with you if you
don't get nervous pull back a bit pull
back a bit
wider shot okay and i remember just
thinking how nervous would you be if you
were
rocking up to the start line to do
something that no human has ever done
before
15 seconds time was really running fast
but 15 minutes before i started warming
up then it was like two minutes five
so it was really going very fast and
sometimes i know
i know i was nervous i was really tense
[Applause]
marathon running is a mental sport and
he will be looking at split times on his
watch
he's got his coach there dutch guy who's
a brilliant brilliant character called
valentine trail
he was keeping up with him on a mountain
bike when the event got underway
i mean it was a a wonderful
pinata bike my role
during the race were just to see if
anything
unexpected would come up either with the
pacing car or with the pacemakers
to be able to give some guidance to get
as smooth as possible through that
situation
all of all the way i used the car to see
on the right times so he's using this
big screen on the car in front of him
to check he's running each kilometer in
the required time
of two minutes 50 seconds per kilometer
but in the end science without the human
being being ready is nothing
he is the one running he is the one
handling the
the pressure he is the one
living for months focusing his mind and
being ready to to handle that pressure
they ran in a kind of arrowhead
formation
so that he was protected and like for
the ordinary
person you don't really think about wind
being a factor
they wanted to remove every single
potential threat to him going under two
hours they needed
perfection absolutely everywhere
at any marathon so many things can go
wrong
something as basic as the laces in a
shoe
come undone and yes
the nature of the marathon is such a
long distance
anything can go wrong and brady is in
vienna this morning
how's he doing how they started off
yeah absolutely textbooks so far uh 10
kilometers done in 28 minutes
it is just incredible my mind actually
was actually on the time and not
unluckily on this
running under two hours so i was
thinking what will happen at
kilometers and also at the last
kilometer
so the big big screen is giving you the
information what pace they're running at
how much time he has in hand on the
record to go under two hours
and then because they're running so fast
every two minutes 50 seconds is a
kilometer falling away
my concern was the splits my concern
was uh energy which i had in my body
is he going to do it that's the big
question is he going to do this
and he just ran ran free
kept going the arrow formation stayed
good
the pacemakers would drop in and drop
out
and once they got past 32 kilometers
anyone who's run the marathon knows in
your head then
i have less than 10 heck now let's take
you to vienna
and if he's going to do it ender is
going to do it in the next few minutes
he's talking anyway i've just worked out
elliot kipchoga has a nine
second cushion and then the gallery at
sky news
they came live to me with a good i'd say
five minutes to the end of the race
seconds he's looking at running the
marathon in 159.51
and then you realize that there's just
me talking commentating
trying to convey this history that's
almost upon us
to the sky news audience all over the
world and they're into the last really
[Music]
my mind was telling me that we are on
today's the day
we'll run under two hours and then five
kilometers a few minutes later down to
four
down to three and i was frantically
sending messages back
to london saying he is 19 seconds in
hand
do not come off this stay with me you
are about to watch history
he's inside the last kilometer now ellie
and kim jogger
inside the last kilometer the last
kilometer i feel it was really a joy in
my heart
because i i was sure i will just i will
run under 12
[Music]
and i try to push all the time to
make sure that i i really finish
in a good way but also in an energetic
way
what's happening he's coming up beside
us here now
this is out of this world less than 200
meters to go
and the pacemakers they slowed it down
they knew that they'd done their job and
the last 100 meters would be his glory
here he comes he's got one minute to go
now this was the moon landing moment
this was the rock of coming into land
he's pointing he knows he's done him
he knows he's gonna look at him he's
picking up people in the crowd
but i was pointing i actually telling
the people in this side
to celebrate together and decide to
celebrate again
159 for a marathon
here's elliot
[Applause]
[Music]
the first person to climb on the forest
the first person to go to the into the
moon
kipchoga crossing the line in one hour
59 minutes
and 40 seconds 0.02
everyone was just ecstatic and euphoric
for him
because it was just the greatest thing
that could happen to one of the nicest
people you can meet
i hope soon people will run under those
but i'll remain the first human being
however colorado
has just made history
[Applause]
elliot kipchoge's achievement in vienna
has never been officially recognized by
athletics governing body the iaaf
because of the pacemakers and technology
used in his attempt
former kenyan olympic medalist patrick
sang has been
eliad kipchoge's primary coach since
2002
marathon man was written and produced by
robert mulhern
if you want to learn more about this
documentary please visit
dot www.skynews.com forward slash
storycast 21
next time an out of the blue text
message
sparks a dramatic rescue in the aegean
sea
my wife was next to me and wondering why
i was furiously texting
and actually helping to coordinate a
rescue that was taking place
you know a thousand or so miles to the
south
you